هنا في جنديرس المنكوبه قبور احتضنت
عائلات باكملها ابت الا ان تموت معا لتخرج
من اسفل الركام الى اسفل التراب
فمن عرفت هويتهم دفنوا مع عائلاتهم
وجيرانهم
والمجهولون منهم قالوا الى ارقام تكتب على
شواهد القبور حتى ياتي من يبحث عنهم ان
بقي لهم احياء ناحيه عدد ما في عدد انه
يعني مو سمعت انه مثلا مثلا 500 600 700
ما حد بيعرف لا لا في مجهولين جابوا كمان
وفي عائلات مثلا نزل بالقمر عشره ولا
ثمانيه ولا خمسه ولا غير وسواه هيك يعني
على التغسيل كان في جامع صلاح الدين عم
بيخس لو يكفنوه هنيك فصاروا ياخذوا صور
لهم يصورون
ونشر مثلا هذا رقم واحد رقم اثنين رقم
ثلاثه هون على القبور
فاقد حدا كذا على الصوره صار يعرفوا يعني
بناء
كاق واحد وهنا رب اسره مع زوجته واولاده
واسماء جماعيه على شاهد واحد
ومشاعر الم مضاعفه ليس حزنا على الغياب
فقط بل على الحال التي دفن فيها ضحايا
الزلزال ليفوق الوضع طاقه التحمل
يعني
كان في تعاون شعبي كبير لان اعداد كبيره
وسبحان الله كل عائله مع بعضها
ابو عبده الله يرحمه
اخونا اياد هو ودرس واولاده عبيده وزوجته
واولاده
مقابر جماعي
ليست لضحى يا جرائم حرب بل هي القبور التي
احتضنت العائلات السوريه بعد الموت ليصبح
مصطلح لم الشمل والذي يكرره السوري ونفس
كل بلاد وكل حال عنوانا حتى لمثواهم
الاخير الى عمر العربيه